Calendar / Kalender (aka, the fun of locali[zs]ation)
Paul Verbeek-Mast
[Applause]
PAUL: Thank you.
This is the last part of my name, it's Verbeek-Mast,
recently got married and added my girlfriend's
last name to it.
Up until last week I was working at Booking.com
as a front end developer, but I've now joined
a start-up in the Netherlands called SpronQ
and I'm also an organiser of the Fronteers
conference this year, which will be the 10th
anniversary, which is cool.
So I will also not tell you what it all says
but it talks about localisation of a calendar
that we did at Booking.com, so these are almost
all - these are part of the languages that
we localised in, it was 42.
We did not localise in Klingon even though
I really wanted to.
Let me tell you what my talk is not about,
about things we already know, that date and
time is difficult.
If you really want to know what we all think
that's incorrect about time there is a cool
article called Falsehoods Programmers Believe
About Time and, if that's not enough, there's
still More Falsehoods Programmers Believe
About Time and you can look them up.
Very, very cool.
As I said, I was working at Booking.com and
we had this calendar that we used for people
that own an apartment or a small hotel, and
where they can see their reservations, change
the prices and things like that but the problem
was it wasn't actually a calendar, it was
like this infinite scrolling list where you
couldn't see any data on, you have to click
three times before you can get the real data,
so we got a lot of feedback from our users
that it didn't really look like our calendars
that they were using the competitor with the
red logo, which I cannot tell, so we decided
to change the calendar.
We did some user research about what we wanted
to do and so we did implementation and we
started out with making some sketches.
This sketch was made by someone else this
morning, but it's still a cool sketch, but
we started out with some sketches and implemented
our front end and then actually we used Perl
at Booking.com so we had some Perl code and
you actually don't want to touch a lot of
that so we tried to just use the code that
was already there and that was it for the
calendar.
But then we needed to localise.
There are 42 different countries at Booking.com
and even more regions so if you are German
you will know this date format is not really
how it looks in Germany and also you are used
that the euro sign is at the end.
Things like that.
If you look at the US, it will actually - a
week will start at Sunday; the date format
is completely different.
The price is dollars.
And for those dates things, we actually decided
to use Moment.js.
Also not to talk about Moment.js, I will briefly
go through it, what we did use, but Moment.js
has very good localisation data as well.
This morning Matt was talking about js-joda
and date - it's not the right name - date
functions, it should be, and about the ECMAScript
temporal proposals, if you want to know about
those, just go and watch his talk when it's
online.
So we had this - say we have this sketch,
we implement this sketch, and we wanted to
add the names of the weeks all along the top.
We need to know: well, what does the first
day of the week start with?
It starts with Sunday or Monday?
You can easily get that with Moment.js, with
locale data, you can get the first day of
the week and return with a 0 or 1 and then
you can get the names of the week in the locale
which you've selected which will in this case
generate Sunday through Saturday, and we use
that at the top.
Then we needed to get the first day of the
month - well, first day of the calendar which
is interesting because it's not the first
day of the month.
So we used - we could just use start of month
and then start of week, and then get the number
of the date, and the same goes for the end
of the month.
Then just fill them all out.
So that was easily to generate the first part
of the calendar.
Then I needed to find what kind of format
does this country use?
It's not always - it wasn't very easy to find
but it was somewhere in a more private variable
called long date format, and then we used
a capital L, and that was basically it.
So I'm going to go through this very fast
but just to get a sense of what we were kind
of working with.
This was basically the localisation then for
all the languages, very easily.
So then we went on the testing and just going
through the languages to see if everything
is okay, and then I hit the bump that I always
forget, and that is RTL, which stands for
right to left languages.
Those are languages like Arabic or Hebrew
so if you have this calendar it's not only
this script that goes from right to left,
you actually want to change everything from
right to left so for example you want to switch
the right column to the left, and then also
switch everything around as well so that your
Monday also starts on the right side, your
week.
So this is all done in CSS, so you just change
your float left to your float right, your
margin left to your margin right.
If you have something inline or inline block
it will automatically go right.
The only thing is the two arrows, we switch
the functionality around because if you click
on the left arrow you want to go to a month
in the future instead of the past.
We could have just rotated the arrows which
would have been easy with CSS.
So we just clicked through everything, fixed
a few bugs and then we went on to more testing.
If you want to know about unit testing at
Booking.com, you can give me a few beers later
on and I will tell you a whole lot about unit
testing at Booking.com.
I don't work there anymore so I can now tell
you everything I know.
[Laughter]
But what we did was we added just a whole
bunch of our users into a beta group, not
asking them, because why would you ask them?
Just put them in a beta and then add a feedback
at the top where they could do a thumbs up
and a thumbs down and get a little bit of
feedback, just a text area.
What do you want to know about users giving
you feedback?
It is not always that useful.
Most of the time it's just very short strings
like - well, these were the positive ones.
"We finally have a much better overview and
love the new interface."
But they already give you a long thing about
how their life is and how good the calendar
is in their life and how they finally found
the right person that they want to be with
just because you have the new calendar.
There's weird stories in there which I will
not show.
But there's also just some bad things like,
"Hate it, bring the old one back", without
saying why they hate it, and, "Who made this?"
Smiling chocolate ice cream, I think.
But if you really dig into the feedback you
will find some obscure things that they will
tell you which you have to dig through your
code to figure out what was actually going
on.
Because these are bug reports and not in the
sense that you yourself would write a bug
report but, "Hey listen, your reservation
is not showing up", and great, what now, because
I cannot contact the person really.
So what I did do is I saved not enough data.
That was a big mistake for me.
I just saved their user ID and the language
that they selected and I should have done
the user agent and a whole bunch of other
things but I was lazy and I implemented too
late, which is a mistake.
Don't be too lazy with these kind of things.
So I had two things to work with, to do some
bug fixing and those four examples that I
will just give you, that I just gave you,
I will go through them because these were
the four most interesting things that I found
and which caused me a lot of detective work
to figure out what it was.
We had some reservation data on our calendar
as well so it showed you more than just a
blue bar, it showed you the name and things
like that but one person - it's just one random
person said: well, my reservations aren't
showing up.
They gave a little bit more data about which
specific reservation that didn't show up and
it was in October 2016, this is reservation,
the 15th or 16th, it just wasn't there for
him.
And it was weird because I had tested it,
it was working, that's how it usually goes,
it works on my machine, but for him it didn't
work and you don't want that because they
will get overbookings and lawsuits.
So first off, just looking through my code
to see if I could figure out anything which
was a problem and then I thought: well, it
must be some localisation thing because that's
mostly where the problems originate at Booking.com
and I figured out this person lives in Brazil.
So first step: changing the language to Portuguese.
Specifically Brazilian Portuguese because
we have that in the website.
I couldn't reproduce the bug.
So next step: I changed the time zone on my
laptop to be minus 3 because I saw that they
were based in the capital, and it still didn't
show up.
I couldn't reproduce the bug.
Then a colleague sitting next to me said:
here's the bug, I have it.
What?
What did you do?
He said: well, I switched to Portuguese, changed
the time zone to minus 3.
Well, okay, let's just check out any other
settings that we might have and we couldn't
figure it out for a very long time until I
noticed there's a Wiki page on time in Brazil
which gives you a lot of weird data like their
Summer Time is different when they have carnival
during the time when they would normally switch
to Summer Time but also that not their entire
country adheres to Summer Time.
I thought it couldn't be Summer Time, it's
October, but I was just forgetting one of
the falsehoods I believe about time which
is Summer Time is always true in my summer,
which is not true for their hemisphere, of
course, because Summer Time starts in October.
So my colleague selected capital of Brazil
as his time zone and I selected a city just
north of Brazil, and that city north of Brazil
didn't adhere to Summer Time and the capital
did adhere to it, so I found a crappy piece
of code that I wrote which compared two different
dates and there was one thing that says "add
one day", and I learned that in Moment.js
"add one day" does not mean add one day; it
sort of does, but it just adds 24 hours.
Compared with this, it basically meant the
day was never going to be the same because
the day would be one day, and day 3 would
be midnight.
By the way, smart quotes, not fun.
The day there.
Sorry.
So I just switched them around and that was
fixed.
[Laughter]
Great.
I could also fix my code to make it better,
but I was leaving anyway.
So another thing is: why are closed dates
red?
A very obscure question but they came up in
a different kind of string so I could figure
out that it said: this date, if they closed
it, so I don't accept any reservations, we
show this red bar.
Well, that's good, right?
So what do you think of this?
Is this a good day at the stock market?
I wouldn't think so, but this is a very good
day at the stock market because in eastern
Asia, red often means that it's something
good instead of something bad.
So their convention is something is closed
and you are showing this is good?
It's not very fun because sometimes you show
that it's good even though they close it because
they have a funeral or something, and you
don't want to do that, so we switched it around
to make it grey and that was neutral enough
for people, so learning from this, just watch
out with colours because you can do things
wrong for some countries.
So the third one is that the day selection
is not working.
This was our date selection, with a From and
a To, and when you click on it, it showed
your jQuery, your date picker.
Why jQuery UI date picker?
Well, because we had already used it and we
are just re-using things.
At first, it's not a big problem but you cannot
see what date and what month it is so you
have to get the date format for a moment to
see: okay, this is month, day, year.
Then, if you want to change that, if you want
to connect it with the date picker you can
do parse date and then it says month, day,
year, and you add the date.
But this gives an error.
This does not work because jQuery UI uses
this format.
Month, day, year, lower case, and then the
year changes to yy, so I created a little
script for it.
I already did this, so it was before the bug
showed up.
So I created a script, put it - by the way,
I hope you will not need it - but the problem
with this script led in this part.
If you were here a couple of talks before
about regular expressions, this is a very
easy regular expression, it kind of finds
the slashes and dashes in the day format,
you have to figure out where the delimiters
are.
If you are from Germany you've probably already
figured out a problem because most complaints
come from German users.
It also needed a dot because the format in
Germany mostly is a dot in between, so I thought:
well, what the hell, let's just change it
to /W and then be done with it.
Most people didn't report a bug anymore except
for one country, and I told you that I saved
the language of the country, and I actually
saved the full language name, so I saved this
for the country that was the problem.
So I thought: okay, which language is that?
So I used my very great tool for that, Google
Translate.
Google Translate said: okay, I've detected
this is Slovenian.
Are there any in the room by the way?
Any Slovakians in the room?
So the top one is Slovakian, and the bottom
one is Slovenian.
It's a slight difference.
So after I checked it's Slovenian and thought:
still not seeing the bug - and then it says
in the bottom, "Did you mean this?", and I'm
like, "No, not really!"
So Google Translate does know that this word
is in Slovak because if you just change the
word to Slovak, it translates it, so what
was the problem here?
The date delimiter was dot space.
Great.
So just adding a plus to my regular expression
fixed everything.
Maybe something else is broken but at least
it fixed this.
The last thing that I want to show you has
nothing to do with date or time; it has something
to do with the prices that weren't showing
up properly.
So we have the reservation, we have the number,
we also showed the prices.
Showed up perfectly fine.
We checked and nobody ever had a price that
was higher than 99,000 euros, so should be
fine.
But yeah, not always.
So this was 1 million Indonesian Rupiah, I
think, so it's not always just about dates
and times, it's also about prices, it's about
changing the colours, it's about cultural
differences as well.
I think I went a little bit too fast but my
conclusion to wrap this up is a couple of
things: so do not make any assumptions.
That's basically what a lot of people have
already said at a number of different conferences
but even if you read all the assumptions that
people make about date and time there's a
lot of assumptions that you are probably going
to make.
And localisation is not just translation.
Translation is a part of localisation.
It's more than that.
It's cultural differences.
It's date and time, it's colours, not just
about date and time but also colours and things
like that.
Gathering meaningful feedback, so not to do
things that I did, it's gathering feedback
from the users, it's great, but just save
their user agent, save the URL that they are
on, save maybe the way you look at languages,
so maybe instead of the Slovenian or the Slovakian
word that I said, just save SK which makes
more sense for programmers.
And bugs will happen.
It doesn't matter how much you test it, it
doesn't matter how much experience you have
in localisation, every time you do something,
bugs will happen and they will always be there,
even if you fix all the bugs that people are
reporting.
It will still be localisation bugs because
sometimes people are just used to localisation
issues, and change their language to English
just so that they know this probably works
better.
But localisation is still important because
if you don't have German language, a lot of
people can't use your website and you will
say I don't have a lot of Germans on my website.
You need to change your language.
It's about accessibility.
And bug fixing is like being a detective,
kind of like being a travelling detective,
because I feel like I have travelled to all
different kinds of regions just to figure
out what the problem was.
I didn't actually travel because if that was
the case that I could travel for bug fixes
I might still be working at Booking.
So have fun with your bug fixes and just feel
like that you are actually trying to find
something that no one else has ever done before.
So thank you very much.
This is my Twitter handle, if you want to
follow Fronteers, this is the Fronteers Twitter
handle.
My email address - I love getting emails.
This is my ICQ number.
Thank you very much.
[Applause]